seven eight six five one with the number  of Nazi Statute on Steam unveils arm the  European Parliament paid tribute to its  first elected president after she passed  away up to seventy billion euros is lost  each year due to corporate tax avoidance  lawmakers want more transparency  multinationals will have to publicly  disclose tax information forty four  percent of electric and electronic  devices could be repaired instead of  being thrown away MEP s want to tackle  planned obsolescence and make good  easier to repair six point four billion  euros was left over from 2016 EU budget  Parliament is calling on Member States  to use that money to honor their pledges  for refugee aid 30,000 new HIV  infections were reported in Europe in  2015 the diagnosis and hepatitis C cases  are also on the rise any piece are  calling for concrete actions to curb the  diseases  you  [Music]